depuis 38 ans les cabanons de la
calanque des bains des dames font partie
intégrante de cette crique magnifique
près de marseille mais voilà la
préfecture a décidé de les faire démolir
ou non de la loi sur le littoral les
familles qui ont l'habitude de s'y
retrouver ont décidé de se mobiliser
pour préserver ces petites bicoques
yannick aroussi benoît jourdain
c'est l'une des déclinaisons
marseillaise du bonheur 32 mètres
carrées en bord de mer de bons amis un
bon repas un bon verre de rosé
bref la journée au cabanon un quart
d'heure de chez ceux profite au maximum
de cette cette calanque que nous aimons
par dessus tout et que souhaitons garder
le plus possible le bain des dames la
favorite du roi d'espagne venaient s'y
baigner en 1965 des permis de construire
sont délivrés pour ces garages abbatu
nous n'avons pas d'électricité pas de
chauffage pas de sanitaires par contre
nous avons ici de douche pour l ain le
bât blesse car d'après les services de
l'état ces équipements transforme le
garage à bateaux un habitations de
loisirs douce à la libération intégrale
du domaine public maritime
l'autorisation d'occupation temporaire
du domaine public maritime n'est donc
pas renouvelé
adieu le paradis aux soirées jeux car le
mécano devant la cabane en jeu la gatte
depuis ici du coup la tension monte les
cabanonniers ont réuni 1000 signatures
sur une pétition pour tenter de garder
leur place au soleil depuis 38 ans je
dire on est on est là c'est toute une
vie 38 ans et
es-tu son rendement allez on ne balaie
ça comme si c'est fake et christ les
cabanons devront être détruits d'ici la
fin de l'année
la mairie de marseille se réjouit de
voir enfin la loi littoral à pikine